filme de [__] Eu sempre fico pensando
cara quem foi que construiu o quarto é
isso que eu penso que assim bilionário
de filme A gente tem essa história deles
ali mas o quarto já tá ali quando eles
chegam já fizeram e nós tem que botar
uma mãe pode aparecer é isso Junior
algema mano
eu vou longe eu fico pensando que esse
cabra pensa
uh ah meu bem quando eu pegar aquela
pilantra tem tem ele bateu o nível
errado aqui
bicho ai meu amigo a mulher fica torta
Então se fosse alguém que não tivesse um
braço aqui não sei pode ser também mas
até bom é acessibilidade né porque todo
mundo tem o direito sexual amarrado
coisado tá tristes mesmo não tem um
deficiente físico que o sonho é ir na
praia com certeza tem um que diz assim
[__] de praia meu irmão meu negócio é
fazer amor violento